[Music]
hi there Heather again and hello again
for me Jenny I'm a sales trainer for
Google cloud users expect apps to be
available 24/7 and developers also
expect to be able to deploy new versions
of their app multiple times a day on
today's episode we'll introduce google
kubernetes engine we'll also run through
a quick demo of the self-paced lab where
we'll deploy a containerized application
with kubernetes engine let's get started
as a starting point let's take a moment
to discuss containers as well as
kubernetes absolutely
so containers address the problem of how
to easily and consistently deploy apps
in different environments they
essentially allow apps to be broken down
into smaller independent pieces that can
be deployed or managed dynamically
containerization also allows the
separation of apps from infrastructure
which is going to allow developers to
focus on their apps while IT operations
teams can focus on deployment and
management and because containers are so
lightweight individual services can
quickly be called when they're needed
and are available almost immediately
which brings us to kubernetes kubernetes
is a production ready open source
platform and provides a container
centric management environment so
instead of having all of your
applications separate from your
libraries and your kernel each
application has its own library
associated with it resting above a
kernel kubernetes allows you to interact
with your container cluster to deploy
and manage your apps perform
administration tasks and set policies
and monitor the health of your deployed
workloads
google kubernetes engine is the premier
manage kubernetes solution leveraging
Google's infrastructure kubernetes
engine provides the perfect managed
environment for deploying managing and
scaling your containerized apps simply
describe the compute memory and storage
resources your application containers
require in kubernetes engine will
provision and manage the underlying
cloud resources automatically Google
also wants to ensure that your users
have a seamless experience so Google
site reliability engineers or sres
constantly monitor your cluster and its
resources to ensure that your services
are highly available kubernetes engine
auto scaling will also allow you to
handle any increased demand while
scaling back during those quieter
periods from Gmail to YouTube to search
everything at Google runs on containers
google kubernetes engine allows you to
benefit from all that we've learned the
last decade on building container
management systems time again for quick
labs this hands-on lab which will take
about 30 minutes to complete shows you
how to deploy a containerized
application with kubernetes engine you
can check out the link to start the
quick lab here at this point in the lab
you've created a kubernetes engine
cluster and authenticated for the
cluster to deploy a containerized
application you'll create a new
deployment from the Hello app container
image you'll then create a kubernetes
service which is a resource that lets
you expose your application to external
traffic once deployed you can inspect
the deployed service you can then view
the deployed application from your web
browser using the external IP address
with the exposed port well there we have
it we hope you enjoyed this episode and
would love to hear more about how you
would use google kubernetes engine don't
forget to keep visiting our on-air
webinar series quick labs and our blogs
all the links are below you can also
learn more about kubernetes engine
through our on-demand courses on
Coursera thanks for watching and we'll
see you soon
last week we reviewed Google App Engine
so that you can focus on launching your
app and not the development class